Is partial order good enough for constructing deterministic
distributed algorithms? It turns out, it may be
sufficient for many situations. The airline reservation example
I started with would work fine with a
partial order of events dictated by Lamport's clock.
But there are situations where there maybe a
need for a total order of events in
the distributed system. Let's look at an example.
Here is an example to illustrate the need for
a total order. I'm going to use my own, personal
life example to illustrate the need for total order.
I have, one car and my family consists of
my wife, my son and my daughter, and we
share this single car. And what we want to do
is make sure that we can make local decision
on who gets dibs on using the car at any
point of time. And we're going to use Lamport's clock for this.
So what we do is, whenever we want to get the
car for our personal use, we're going to text everyone with a
time stamp. I'm going to associate a time stamp, if I'm, if I'm
requesting the car, I'm going to text every one, and associate a
time stamp with that request. And it is a logical time-stamp
and similarly my wife would do the same thing, son and
daughter all of us do the same thing. And how do we
pick the winner, well, locally we can look at the
time-stamp of request that have come in from others and my
own request. And whoever has the earliest time stamp wins. Pretty
simple, right? So pretty simple, everybody is going to make a
local decision, looking at the time stamps of request that
have come in from others and say well, you know right
now, it's my son's turn to use the car, or my
daughter's turn to use the car and so on. But what
if the time stamp, because these are locally generated by
each one of us, happens to be the same. So, for
instance, let's say my son makes a request. Takes, sends a
text message. My son makes a request, sends a text message
with a time stamp ten to all of us. So this
is the blue arrow that's going everywhere, so that's indicating to
all three of us that he wants the car, and timestamp
ten is when he generated the request. So happens, my wife
also makes a request for using the car, exactly
with the same timestamp ten. And that's the purple
arrow that you see. So, now we have a problem. And the problem is, all of us are
looking at these text messages and trying to make
a decision, who's got the dibs on using the
car? How will my son and my wife know,
given that both the time stamp is the same,
which one is the winner for using this car?
Now, what we do is, we're going to break the
tie, and I'm going to stipulate that age wins. And
therefore, in this case, if the time stamp happens to
be exactly the same, then my wife, by seniority, is
the winner. She gets the car. So, that's how we
break the tie. You can see, through this example, that
there is a need for total order in decision making
when you have a distributed system. And you want
to make local decisions without bothering anyone, based on
information that you have, but you have to make
that local decision unambiguously, because you cannot have both
my son and wife thinking that they have the
car at the same time. That'll be a problem.
So, whenever there is a tie, we have to
break that, and that's the need for the total order.